as cities across the country consider
returning to strict coveted mandates we
are reminded how the pandemic tested our
faith not our beliefs per se but our
freedoms to openly practice them in
public despite the fact that massive
protests were endorsed by the experts
churches were forced to remain closed
because govern thankfully americans
pushed back
pastor and musician sean floyd was
determined in not to let politics come
before church
that's why he founded the lettuce
worship movement a series of outdoor
concerts during summer 2020. now he's
launching a new tour kicking off in
miami on new year's eve musician and
pastor sean floyd joins me now
in this time we see so many people who
have put
enhanced
importance on different aspects of
american life but it always seemed like
religion was coming last for so many of
our political leaders they didn't seem
to think it was all that important that
people actually be able to gather and
worship together why was it important
for you to make sure that that still
happened
well i just believe you know like
religious like it was an america that
founded religious liberty religious
liberty founded america it's essential
to who we are and
you know especially in a time of a
pandemic especially in a time where
there's such division and there's such
isolation we got to get together we got
to worship we gotta seek god like he is
the answer and the hope for america
you know i think that one of the things
that was so eye-opening to me was to see
the the willingness of so many people
who i considered to be strong believers
to nonetheless go along with a lot of
the different policies that were put in
place without any kind of objection and
it surprised and disappointed me in some
respects so i was encouraged to see you
and the work of some others like you who
have put
religion first and put it back at the
center of our discussion in american
life
what were the things that really
motivated you to do that and what were
the reactions that you experienced from
people across the country when you were
bringing these uh these events to their
communities
well i was so blindsided just like you
ben i mean i i you know we've sing these
songs we preach these sermons and yet
when the moment comes when we got to
practice some it's like
people were you know deserted they just
they just fell at the feet of the
government and i tell people across
america this is not political this is
biblical like we have the mandate as
believers we've been doing it for 2000
years we've been gathering together
you know despite pandemics and
persecution and fear and crazy
tyrannical governors like we have here
in california we've been gathering
together and worship and we've been
worshiping and you know now more than
ever when americans are facing such
darkness you know the light shines in
the darkness and the darkness cannot
overcome it
and so we experienced we went from city
to city you know we went some of the to
some of the hardest and darkest city
cities of riding like seattle and you
know portland we went through los
angeles south chicago and everywhere we
went the story was the same people
gathered needing hope people gathered
needing life it was like there's this
connection that comes in community that
people didn't have but also a connection
to god and the testimonies are crazy you
know thousands of people gathering
people getting saved people getting
healed people giving their life to jesus
getting rid of their addictions i mean
this is why we did this this is why we
launched lettuce worship and we're not
stopping now
well pastor ford i want to wish you the
best of good fortune in the coming year
and thank you for your continued service
thank you so much thanks so much